1162 versus estimates of
1016 uh so I know what you're going to
say Corey so just say it what it's big
profit great big quarter best quarter of
the company ever had I thought you were
going to tell me how wrong the analysts
were they were you know oh wow they were
wrong but uh big big big beat there 1162
I want to see the rest of the numbers
what do you think initial reaction a
little surprised at the bottom line I
want to see the rest I want to see the
rest of the units but definitely better
on the bottom line we've got we' got to
see how everything else shook out here
and the big the big change here is the
buyback program is going to go from 60
billion to 90 billion so clearly you
know listening to icon to some degree
Carl icon tiny
little Carl ion's voice actually getting
and listen to yeah well just his voice
Paul Koski is joining us as well uh from
the West Coast he's a or was an early
stage Venture investor is an early stage
Venture investor and Bloomberg a
contributing editor uh here we go Apple
saying it sees a s for one stock split
it's boosting its buyback to 90 B
million dollars I mean 10 billion
billion short of what Carl icon was
asking for uh your reaction to this
Paul yeah they're pushing every button
and turning every dial they can you know
these are this is financial engineering
of course it doesn't have a lot to do
with the core business but nevertheless
it's uh it's the kind of stuff you do
whenever you don't have products you
know new products to talk about and you
know kudos for them for doing it because
they're under a lot of pressure to do
exactly this kind of thing I think the
the real question is you know I think
Corey was Brian earlier was mentioning
is you know what are the numbers going
to look like the Blended margins were
you know a little higher than people
were expecting and I think that's
important and the bottom line looked a
little better but you know seeing the
actual units will be important here
story to tell I agree this is actually
going to be significant they're
reporting a gross margin of uh of 39%
39.3% this is a big deal you know about
18 months ago Apple started to see a
decline in their gross margins and what
the company said at the time was that
all of their new products were at the
top of the cost curve well here we are
about 18 months later and now they're
seeing the benefit of a lot of the
products actually seeing you know
they're cheaper to build now if you take
a look at you know the cost of building
the iPhone the components inside the the
cost of building the iPad those are a
lot cheaper now and apple seeing a
margin benefit moving towards 40% this
is a big surprise this is going to be a
real positive tomorrow also goes a long
way towards management credibility too
because they said this was going to
happen they said don't worry the margin
hit we're taking is temporary not long
term and now you see margins that's
right and I think this is also showing
us is a philosophical Choice by Apple to
really they want to be where the profits
are not where the the most revenues and
the least profits are which is where you
see xiaomi and HTC and and Samsung sort
of going after market size but not Mark
well and this is a and and this is a Tim
Cook kind of business right I mean this
these are the dials that Tim Cook likes
to turn if he tells you he's going to
improve margins that's because he's got
20 years of improving margins if he
tells you he's going to launch a ground
a groundbreaking new product I'd say
yeah maybe maybe not when he tells you
he's going to do something on the margin
front well that's what he's done for a
decade inside of Apple agreed agreed and
what's critical here is that this is a
stock that I think is has been largely
ignored by investors for the last year
or so and this is the kind of thing that
I think is going to help shift investor
sentiment margins are something they've
been beat up on now it's going to be a
question of what can the company do
between the month of June and the month
of November when we when they have their
worldwide developer conference and we
see what they're doing on their
operating system side is their new
hardware and then what do we see in the
fall with the large screen iPhone 6 what
is this wearable that we all believe is
coming but this is a great start to kick
off that period from June to November
where I think Apple really has an
opportunity to shift in sentiment and
get people back into the name a name
that is largely under owned um you know
across the investor base around the
globe it's interesting stuff and and I
think that you know we'll wait and see
what we see about new products too I
mean that's it it is going to be a key
driver but as I mentioned earlier you
know the the company's gotten to be so
huge I mean here we are second quarter
you're seeing 46 billion dollar in
revenues I mean when they launched the
iPad the company is doing 15 billion in
quarterly revenues so it's and including
have we seen the actual uh have we seen
the actual unit numbers didn't see them
earlier did they beat the 377 on the
iPads yeah I'm actually I'm looking for
that right now funny you should mention
that Paul but um yeah so they s 16 16.4
uh million I'm sorry billion uh uh iPads
iPhone was 44 43.7 so the iPhone is
better than expected a lot of people
including myself expected a number in
the high 30s so that's actually quite a
bit better on the on the iPhone side the
iPad is a bit lower the street was
closer to 20 million on the IP sounds
light so this is going to be light for
iPad better for iPhone you know what's
interesting is we have seen um you know
a number ofo prr this right I we
expected to a degree but this is
actually much better on iPhone than than
so so that's some good news but I mean
these sales have been pretty much soft
on the iPad front nobody was expecting
really great things everybody keeps
saying you need to wait until there's a
product that's fair but it's still a
Miss it's still a miss and I think that
that's what that it's going to be a
mixed read tomorrow but the good news is
is that better iPhones you know worse on
the iPad side but this gross margin
thing is a great indicator of what's to
come I think investors are going to are
going to pour into this name tomorrow
and own it because we're ahead of a
significant product cycle that like I
said is going to start in June we're
like we could get a new payment platform
announced we're going to definitely see
some new hardware on the Mac side new
iPhones and iPads in the fall a wearable
in the fall so this tomorrow I think
people investors come back to Apple
starting tomorrow and what it suggests
is that the sales of the iPhone were of
the higher end iPhone because the
margins are so much higher for the
overall business and that maybe actually
actually Cory it's actually mixed
because the iPhone 5c is effectively
it's a pretty cheap phone to build those
are the same Parts those are the same
parts from the iPhone 4 and they still
charge a premium price for it so I
actually think that this gross margin
benefit is coming from the iPhone 5 as
yeah as well as well as the 5c so I
actually think it's it's a healthy Mi I
got to say this is just unbelievable the
90 billion $90 million worth of buyback
I mean that that's that's huge it's a
it's a significant bump up and you know
what's funny I didn't believe that Carl
icon was going to have much of an of an
impact here and uh this is evidence that
you know he wasn't the only one who was
asking fory but he was the most vocal
one and uh and I I'll be interested to
hear what his response is to this
tomorrow because this is definitely a
better use of C course clarify that
billion billion billion billion I mean
it's just in a massive massive amount he
was calling for 100 billion he's pretty
much got it we thought that he was a we
thought that he was backing away from
this he he thought that he just couldn't
win this but it seems like and you know
you know to be fair though they needed
to do it right like people need to be
excited about this stock there's really
no reason to get excited without the new
prodct unless you I mean this is the
problem you know they they've had this
air pocket of new products that's been
probably one of the longest in the
company's recent history with sort of
non-iterative releases yeah it's
incredible and so you know you had to do
this kind of stuff and you can expect
now that you know activists like icon or
M balen he's not going to be the last
one pounding on their door if the
products this fall don't light a growth
you know light a growth F under the
stock this is going to continue because
he's cook has essentially shown that
he's willing to fold on these things and
if that's a button he has to press to
support the stock you'll press that
button and you know if you line up all
the key the key five things that
investors care about in this name four
of them are a positive the iPhone's a
positive this buyback is going to be a
significant positive to especially a lot
of the longer term investors who want to
hold Apple over a 5year period this is
going to be a real positive the gross
margin story I can't emphasize enough
how meaningful this is to see margins
ticking back towards that 40% range
where they were for a long time you know
36% 37% that's not acceptable to a lot
of investors so investors are going to
ride this momentum tomorrow and this is
actually interesting to watch how this
performs from tomorrow all the way
through November but I think this is
going to Mark a change we're going to
see a lot of positive commentary from
analyst tomorrow and it's going to be an
interesting one to watch can I give you
a big picture number from Cory's model
which means the numbers are probably
right um iPhone units cumulative so
since they introduced the iPhone they
have sold 516 million iPhones and 212
million iPads it's just an
amazing which decimated the the the
notebook Market well you know you've
been positive on this stock I got to say
you've been very positive all along
despite the sort of chorus of naysayers
uh so do you feel somewhat Vindicated at
I do I do but at the same time I
actually this this iPhone number is even
better than I thought I actually have
have thought that that the iPhone number
was going to be a bit muted because the
iPhone 5c really hasn't sold that well
it hasn't sold that well in a lot of
markets but what this shows is the
iPhone the 5S the newest model is still
doing well and and the iPhone 5c may be
doing better and some of these new
programs they've initiated in the last
quarter where they're offering you know
different types of rebates and lower
price points it's work so I have been
surprised because I actually I was a
little bit muted about the March quarter
what what this would what this would
what this would end up looking like but
bullish on the rest of the year and
what's great is that I think that's
going to be the right call going forward
and I'm anxious to see how the market
reacts okay